네 안녕하세 빌사남 있니다 어 제가
오늘은 좀 특별한 분을 모셨는데 저희
bsn 스터디도 들으시고 이번에 또
건물도 매입하셨으면
좀 자기소개 부탁드리겠습니다네 저는
샤로수길에서 주벤 쿠바를 운영하고
있는 원석입니다 일단은 건물 이번에
좀 투자하는데 좀 어떻게 투자하는지
좀 구독자분들이 되게 좀 궁금해하실
것 같아요 근데 그거를 일단 말하기
전에 좀 어떤 일을 주로 하셨는지
그런 부분에 대해서네 원래는 회사를
다녔었고 삼성 sds 5년 정도
다니다가 나와서 이제 창업을 하는
케이스인데 운영하면서 뭐 2호점
3호점 4호점 하는 와중에 이제 저희
주구가 본점 이르는 건물을 요번에
매입을 하게 됐습니다네 보통은 그
이제 임차한 생각을 하는데 건물
투자까지 생각을 못하거든요 건물
투자를 이렇게 생각하게 된 계기가 좀
있으실까요 저희 상이 샤 이라는
상권이 있는데 거의 10년 가까이
됐는데 10년 동안 보면서 가게들이
잘 되다가 이렇게 없어지는 경우도
많이 왔어요 그리고 제가 예전에
좋아했던 이태원 뭐 홍대 쪽을 봐도
잘하시던 사장님들이 뭐 월세 오르고
이래서 다른 지역으로 어쩔 수 없이
가시는 모습을 많이 봤어 가지고 제가
장사를 진심으로 할 거면 어이 자리를
안정적으로 할 수
있어야겠다 그 측면이 일단 제일
컸고요 그러면 뭐 월세나 이런 부분에
있어서도 제가 그렇게 부담이 안
될테니까 재 건물에서 한다면 음식
가격이나 이런 것도 합리적으로 할 수
있고음 아니나다를까 샤로수끼리 월세가
엄청나게 올랐거든요네 밥집들이 가격도
많이 올리고 아니면 술집으로 업종
전환되는 거 봤을 때는 내가이 사업을
안정적으로 하려면 건물이 꼭 있어야
될 것이다음이 생각을 일단 가장 먼저
했었어요 아 금액을 한 어느 정도에
매입 하신 거죠 금액은 제가 최종으로
22억에 매입을 했고요 대출은 제가
17억 네네를 대출을 받았습니다
그러면 22억에 17억을 빼면
실제로는 5억이 필요했던 거잖아요
근데 그 5억도 4층에 주택이 있어서
주택 이제 보증금이 1억 7천 있었고
이제 저 1 2 3층에 또 가게가
있어요 가게들 보증금이 또 3천이
있어서 실제로는 3억에 구입했다고
보셔도 아 3억이네 그 아무래도
빌딩이 그래도 대출이 좀 잘 나왔어
가지고 실투자금이 많이 안 들어간
건데 그 제가 알고 있기로는 법인으로
산 걸로 알고 있거든요네 맞습니다
처음부터 좀 법인 매입을 생각하셨나요
어 제가 이제 김수 대표님 강의를
들었었지아요 강의를 들으면서 법인을
그때 조금 제대로 알아봤던 거 같고
은행에 가서도 제가 상담을 많이
받아봤어요 은행에 가면 어 왜
개인으로 사실 법인으로 잘 생각을
하냐 어 그게 뭐 나중에
세금적인거나 하고 있으면 장점이 많다
근데 대출은 잘 안 나온다 근데 막상
그런 말을 들었지만 대표님이랑 같이
그런 스터디를 받았었고 법인으로 살
때 유리한 점이 또 많더라고요 그래서
뭐 일단 대출 금액이 쉬시게 잘
나온다 그 부분이 있었고 금리도 제가
봤을 때는 5% 받았거든요 아 5%
받았어요 괜찮게 받았네요 그때 한참대
때였는데네 거의 뭐 6% 7% 많이들
받을 때 딱 5.0에 받았어요 아
추가적으로 제가 작은 오피스텔을 하나
갖고 있었는데 이것까지 담보를 같이
설정을 해가 그래서 막판는 조금 더
내렸어요 그렇게 하니까 실제로
들어가는 비용이 상당히 낮아진 것도
있고네 어쨌든 제가 장사를 하고 있는
건물이니 제가 원래 월세가 다를 거
아니에요 그 월세를 이자로 치환한다
생각했을 때는 저는 이게 너무나 더
맞다라고 생각이 딱 들더라고요 지금
그러면 은 대출 이자가 5월 어느
정도 나가시죠 한 750 정도
나갑니다 750이네 그 원래 기존에
임대료 냈던게 어느 정도 되시죠 제가
한 280 정도 내고 있었고요 아
280네 다른 층에서 나오는 것까지
합치면 그렇죠 그것까지 하면 월세가
그래도 400 이상은 들어오죠 아
400이 예이자 감당해도 좀 뭐
그렇게 부담 안 되네네 리즈너블한
가격에서 감당도 할 수 있고 근데
저희 같은 경우에는 제가 여기를
4억으로 쓰고 싶어서 매입을 한
케이스거든요 그니까 단순하게 저희네
층만 아 나 안 나가고 여기서
오래오래 장사할 거야이 마음도 당연히
깔려 있었지만 저희가 지하도 있고 총
5층짜리 토탈 여섯 개 층인 거죠
여섯 개 층이 남은 공간들에서 제가
할 수 있는 것들이 또 생긴다고
봤어요 저희 같은 경우에는 식자재를
많이 쓰니까 지금 식자재가 매장 안에
너무 꾸역꾸역 들어가 있는 거를 지하
공간에 좀 펼쳐서 내리면 저희
음식점도 더 공간을 쾌적하게 쓸 수
있 있을 것이다 그렇게 되면 유통으로
저희가 마진을 더 볼 수 있습니다
그다음에 2층에서 카페 지금 잘 하고
계시고 3층이 제가 사무실점 쓰고
있는데 여기를 완전히 뭐 스튜디오로
바꾸고 제가 5층으로 저희 사무실을
옮길 거예요 아 네네 그렇게 되면은
또 하나의 상업 공간이 생길 수
있다는 거죠 그리고 4층은 주택이 돼
있는데 저는 아직 집이 없습니다 막
나중에 제가 들어가서 아 거 거주도
해도 되니까 그럼 또 집세도 아낄 수
있는 거고 저는 요번에 구입을 해
보면서
상가주택이 상당히 효율적이고
괜찮다라는 생각을 좀 많이 했어요네
그리고 어디로 안 쫓겨 놔도
되고 건물 사고나서 좀 이렇게 달라진
건 있으세요 혹시이 처음에는 뭔가
사면은 막 막 드라마틱한게 있을 것
같았는데 남자분들은 공감하실 수도
있는데 저녁 하는 날 세상을 다 가진
거 같은 느낌이 물론 들지만 들고
나서 하루 딱 자고 나면은 아 그래
내가 그 저녁을 했구나 그러잖아요
그래서 그래서 처음에는 이제 등기 딱
나오고 이러면 되게 기분 좋았는데
지금은 되게 덤덤하고 크게 바뀐
거라기보다는 좀 쫓기는 마음은 없어진
거 같아요 쫓기는 마네 그 장사하시는
분들 중에 이렇게 건물 투자를
생각하시는 분들이 좀 있으실 것
같거든요 그래서 그분들한테 혹시 좀
조언을 해줄 만한 그런 얘기가 좀
있을까요 그 자리에서 안정적으로
오해영 을 하실 분들은 당연히 매입을
하시는게 좋을 거 같고요 근데 매입을
하실 때 개인으로도 매입할 수 있지만
법인으로 메이비 좋은
이유는 거의 뭐 30년이 넘었죠
지금도 실은 요식업 경기가 좋지는
않거든요 어 저희가 그러면 서비스 예
저희가 무조건